Darry walked in on his parents [ __ ]
when you were like 23 years old right
Gary do I have that right oh yeah yeah
it was fine it was awful
he was [ __ ] awful you know what it
was one of those nights where I went out
for the night so my parents probably
thought the coast was clear but then I
forgot something
in fact I forgot that it was supposed to
help my father carry a sofa to the you
know to the street for special pickup so
it didn't even dawn on me that they'd be
having sex well so when I walked in i
just opened the door right up and the
covers were on the but there were
candles lit all around the room woman my
father was on top of my mother so so no
position were they in like a missionary
yeah
but then if she wasn't doing reverse
cowgirl so so now I go out to the living
room and I'm I'm like stunned I like I
don't know what to do you know I'm like
I'm like traumatized and my father comes
out in his underwear smoking a cigarette
and he goes you know this is very
embarrassing for all of us and I'm like
it that please stop talking and then
there's a long pause he goes would you
think we were dead you mean you didn't
shirk off like Ronnie did your mom and
dad in a threesome I was out yeah and I
came in on it always close oh so you
just heard what you could hear what the
[ __ ] was going on
did you beat off while they were doing
it it's possibility how [ __ ] up is
Ronnie that he just talks yeah Gary
could you imagine going to your room and
jerking off after you cut your parents
parking I couldn't even breathe right
Ronnie lay down near the door and sort
of I've seen your parents are very sexy
Ronnie what did you see with your mother
oh and what did you see with your father
a streaks oh ok so he must've been in
the mission